plants one of the foundations of life on
Earth yet so often taken for granted in
the modern world there's this thing
called green blindness where we just see
plants as a big massive green without
plants we don't have life if we didn't
have those big trees we'd have fewer
birds fewer mammals fewer insects now
there's a growing movement to return to
our roots and embrace the natural
walking around a garden you feel better
we want people to understand the
importance of plants and function the
role that they play in protecting life
on Earth trees provide us everything
that we need they take in our carbon
dioxide to make oxygen from preserving
the planet to improving our health how
can we uncover the surprising secrets
plants hold the next drugs that could be
used for cancer things like diabetes
clogs are the future we can learn from
what Mother Nature has already
discovered behind acres of lush greenery
and over 250 years of history lies a
garden that holds the keys to unlocking
the true potential of real botanicals
you can imagine the amount of
information it's at their fingertips so
exciting we now have the possibility to
answer these questions the world's top
botanists are on a mission inspired by
science and nature to reveal the raw
power magical qualities and stunning
beauty of plants we really are just
scratching the surface here the most
biodiverse place on the planet isn't the
Amazon rainforest
it's just outside one of the biggest
cities in the world London England
we have 75% of all plant species from
over 115 countries the Royal Botanic
Gardens Kew sits on 300 sprawling acres
of beauty just in terms of per unit area
we've got more species in more variation
than anywhere else on the planet
it's here they strive to understand how
the natural elements inside plants or
botanicals can be used to better our
lives all life depends on plants without
plants we don't have life we need plants
for food medicine fuel pretty much all
of our basic needs are primarily met by
plants Hughes mission is to be the
global resource for plants and fungal
knowledge and what that means is we want
people to understand the importance of
plants and fungi in the role that they
play in protecting life on Earth we have
over 300 scientists working to resolve
questions about the evolution of plants
why they matter and why we should
conserve them as well but before they
were the global authority on plants Q
began as a garden created by England's
royalty nearly 260 years ago
so coo started in 1759 and it was
created by Princess Augusta and Prince
Frederick around the mid 1700s princess
Augusta died her son George the third
took over the garden though it's King
George who really took things to the
next level he was really fascinated by
the natural world and here ployed plant
collectors to go out into the world and
find rare unique just sometimes really
unusual plants and they brought them
back to cure by the mid-1800s
the new director of Kew met an ambitious
young naturalist and the two formed a
lasting friendship Charles Darwin was a
close friend of Joseph Hooker and we
have sketches notes drawings from his
famous voyage on the Beagle we also have
plant samples from that voyage those are
hugely valuable to science and Darwin
used hooker as a bit of a sounding board
for his new ideas and in fact Origin of
Species wouldn't be what it is today
without that relationship almost 200
years later Hugh now receives nearly two
million annual visitors to explore the
awe-inspiring grounds and architectural
marvels so one of the most special
places at Q is the temperate house
[Music]
it's the world's largest remaining
Victorian glass house it's absolutely
huge we've got ten thousand Rowan
endangered plants in there from all four
corners of the world so this is the
living collection of a Lowe's that the
display in the Princess of Wales
conservatory here at Hugh it's just the
tip of the iceberg we have many other
species of aloes cultivated behind the
scenes as well
so in 2008 we built the treetop walkway
it's in the center of the Arboretum and
it looks out over this incredible
tapestry of trees here at Kew we have
14,000 trees in the Arboretum a huge
number every country every continent is
represented here trees are like people
and one thing that people don't know is
that trees are Moody and they get
stressed but they're beautiful when
they're happy and one of our jobs is to
ensure that all our trees are distressed
and happy without trees the world would
fall out of balance
there's a thing called green blindness
where we just see plants as a big
massive green and we might think that
they're beautiful but we don't
appreciate the diversity of plants and
the importance of diversity in plants
there's a wealth of material in that
tree so there'll be backs in that tree
there's fungus in that tree there's a
huge number of insects that all use
actually as a home and that is really
important if we didn't have those big
trees we'd have fewer birds fewer
mammals fewer insects and less foliat
beyond the natural beauty lies the
scientific backbone of cue
the herbarium a vaults of the world's
plant knowledge going back to Darwin
himself so the herbarium to me is the
heart serves the the science at cute
houses the main collection of estimated
over seven million different dried
plants samples here that represent the
diversity of plants you know on our
planet
professor Monique Simmons leads a team
that uses this historical database to
compare with botanicals in the present
here we have a sample from from Darwin
collected from the Galapagos Islands
back in 1835 something to look at but
it's also a tool that we can use in our
research it's really a kind of a
privilege to be part of this you know
the history of our understanding of
plant evolution
Q also recognizes the importance of
collecting and preserving plants for
generations to come
millennium seed bank can wake us is a
global storage facility for wild seeds
it was set up in the year 2000 it is
basically a huge deep storage for the
world's endangered seeds there are 2
billion seeds and that number is growing
every year is that brilliant insurance
policy against natural disasters
man-made disasters and indeed climate
change for example in the British Virgin
Islands they got absolutely mauled by
hurricane
hurricane comes completely wipes out the
forests if that forest is not able to
recover on its own we can provide seed
to repatriate and restore that habitat
plants are critical to providing
solutions that can improve humanity the
work that we do here at Kew will greatly
influence what we plant we're looking at
trees and how they respond to climate
change how they respond to pests and
diseases aloe vera and its relatives all
seem to show really strong
characteristics towards drought
tolerance these adaptations could prove
really useful to us in the future and
the climate change scenarios
to help conserve plants it often helps
if you can show a use it has an economic
value and therefore it can justify that
plant being grown especially if it's a
in a forest plant and if they can be
then linked in with a supply chain for a
product that is going to have a long
history for use etc then you gain to
support not only the justification of
those plants being used but those
communities and to us that's very
important because it helps conserve
plant diversity through their centuries
of experience Q is uniquely suited to
identify and verify botanicals that can
heal and protect our bodies from damage
behind the scenes that q is kind of
unlocking the secrets that plant can
take those ingredients that could be the
next drugs that could be used for cancer
for things like diabetes a key area of
interest is is antibiotics etc we really
face big problems and plants have to
defend themselves against bacteria so
how do we capture that this mission
brought q and one of the largest hair
care brands in the world Herbal Essences
together and a groundbreaking
partnership to bring their findings to
everyone on a global scale
a major breakthrough has been unearthing
the protective benefits of a botanical
called histidine found in many ordinary
plants histidine is an amino acid amino
acids are the building blocks naturally
found in our hair and our skin and
implants it's an essential amino acid
and the fermentation of corn is a very
good source its antioxidants which means
that it gets rid of all binds to kind of
free radicals that are there they're
associated with stress it was also
important because it helps bind to
metals we are able to use this
ingredient to improve the health of hair
the histidine is able to neutralize all
of those free radicals so if you has no
covering or something like that it can
help reduce the amounts of copper
exactly and we know copper is one of the
culprits when it comes to damaging hair
working with the botanist at Kew gives
me an opportunity to understand why
these ingredients are so beneficial for
your hair histidine is just one example
of an amazing botanical that exists in
nature taking plants like rosemary we're
trying to capture that pure essence in
the quest to improve our lives with more
natural solutions q is investigating
plants grown and harvested all over the
world aloe is full of rich vitamins and
nutrients we can't do everything with
argan oil sometimes in unexpected ways
there's goats that literally climb up
the trees to get the Argan fruit
[Music]
within the walls of the Royal Botanic
Gardens Kew is the most diverse
collection of plants in the world but
their purpose is fueled by a deep
connection with the outside world where
botanicals are at their best plants a
part of nature and nature is variable
were currently looking and
authenticating identifying all the
material that is used that's our
starting point
[Music]
5,000 miles away from Q in London a
familiar yet incredible botanical
thrives in the dry climate of the
southwestern US and Mexico
so the aloe juice or extract is full of
all these amazing polysaccharides so
amazing that many people drink them
there's something that you can use on
your skin topically aloe is full of rich
vitamins and nutrients aloe is not just
a house plant common for treating
sunburns it's been used for centuries
for its ability to heal and hydrate I
think one of the key things is it's it's
like a long traditional for being used
for skin for treating wounds aloe has
very interesting moisturizing properties
now q is working to unlock the secrets
of how this super succulent works my
question is a botanist is what makes
aloe vera special this is just one
species and a genus of over 500 very
closely related species but somehow over
thousands of years this particular
species was selected by people and
preferred or favored for its medicinal
uses so my first experience was really
seeing the power of plants I was walking
the class one day with a friend and she
had a bug bite on her leg so there was
an aloe plant and she leaned down broke
off a piece and started just applying
the the liquid inside it to her leg and
I said what are you doing and she said
anytime you have a problem with your
skin and you have irritation you should
just break off a leaf of the aloe plant
so that was my first experience with the
power of botanicals aloe vera is
sustainably sourced by hand two or three
leaves at a time
this process ensures the future health
and benefits of the plant aloe vera is
such an iconic plant many of us have it
growing on our windowsills
there's just something between people
and aloe vera that makes us cultivate
this plant and use it at the moment we
just don't have an answer for what the
magic ingredients in aloe vera is
[Music]
on the tip of North Africa
another amazing botanical is found with
a surprisingly unique origin argan oil
comes from the fruit for the organ
plants and it's usually found in very
dry conditions Argan trees are all the
endemic to Morocco
just outside Marrakech the Argan trees
bear fruit in the summer attracting some
very nimble goats there's goats that
literally climb up the trees to get the
Argan fruit the goats then spit out the
seeds which are harvested by hand to
make argan oil once the Argan fruit is
removed
there's the argan seed inside the Argan
seed is pulled away to reveal the
kernels and those kernels are cold
pressed into the amazing argan oil first
the seed is cracked to separate the
outer skin then the kernels are crushed
inside a traditional machine to make a
liquid paste which is squeezed into
argan oil the results of this process
yield vitamins and nutrients with many
natural health benefits
we can do everything with argon oil gold
liquid goods it's good for us to eat and
good for the cholesterol diabetes and
hypertension because the argan oil rich
of vitamins B and omega-3 six and nine
argan oil also good for eczema acne
psoriasis or strata it has a profile of
fatty acids that differ from other fruit
that's really a key for this particular
plant why it's evolved to do that we
actually still don't really know but
those essential oils again have
antioxidant properties they also have
moisturizing and they give shine to hair
[Music]
like humans plants have their own unique
fingerprints and they're the key to cues
research behind the scenes were looking
at kind of the secrets that are
associated with those plants how do you
capture that knowledge exactly which of
the plants that do that
[Music]
botanicals like aloe and argan oil are
best when sourced in nature but that
makes them variable now cues found a way
to identify and authenticate the quality
of botanicals that come from wild plants
so how we can use the collections of cue
is to find the plants that have the
activities that people are interested in
that's the first stage fingerprint them
so we have an idea of the chemistry
that's associated with the bio activity
and that is a really key element of the
the projects that we're doing Monique
and her team have modeled unique
patterns for key botanicals just like a
human fingerprint comparing them against
200 years of historical archives from
the herbarium this 3d model of a
botanical fingerprint the white one has
these extra Peaks that are really high
this extract was taken in the springtime
and it had tons of sugar for this
extract it was taken during the winter
when the tree is dormant so this will
tell us the quality of our extracts we
want to make sure that we're extracting
it at the right time of the year you can
go further and give an indication often
of the concentration of the different
ingredients
so you've got the diversity which is
showing you that this actually has gone
far more Peaks what we're trying to do
here behind the scenes at Q is Harbor
the the secrets that contained in plants
for a whole range of things so
understanding wound healing about being
able to say that capture the beauty of
plants q scientists are now capable of
verifying the quality of dozens of
botanicals that go into Herbal Essences
by over new products it's a really
fantastic opportunity for Q to partner
with a global brand and it helps us
spread our scientific message about the
value of plants so here we can take a
plant see example here like rosemary and
we know this has been taxonomically
confirmed only the right species but the
right variety and is of quality and then
by a botanical fingerprinting the
rosemary you understand more about the
useful ingredient can
we can make sure it really is an
authentic good quality that you're going
to use in your products
these important discoveries and real
botanicals make their way to millions of
homes every day we talk to women all
over the world and the demand for
naturally derived ingredients is real so
it's important that you take the science
seriously as you design a product I mean
you cannot just say well I'll drop the
strawberry in there and that'll provide
the benefit that a person thinks they're
gonna get from a strawberry when
someone's standing at the shelf and
trying to decide which one of these
products to buy I think the credential
of the Royal Botanic Gardens Kew will
give them the confidence that they can
trust because of the naturally derived
ingredients inside I think consumers are
increasingly interested in what goes
into the products that they're using
they have the reassurance of knowing
that the plant ingredients have been
identified and authenticated by cue the
world's leading authority on plant
science so a cue we think there are
plant based solutions to many of the
world's critical and pressing challenges
and it's the science that underpins our
understanding of plows that do that Q's
mission is to better our world through
nature and science and together with
Herbal Essences they're changing the
standards in the beauty industry it's
really exciting and important
partnership because we've got so many
fantastic ideas we're looking at new
product development we really believe in
this partnership and the power that it
has importantly the mission that Q has
over all so a portion of all the
proceeds from the sale of these Herbal
Essence bio renew products that are
credentialed by Q go back to Q to help
them continue to fund their mission so
that they will be helping the world for
generations to come
scientists must continue to innovate
plants hold the keys to our future with
the unparalleled ability to improve our
health food beauty climate and lives
the rear you can sum up Q with two words
for beauty and science and the fact that
we have 350 scientists sick you who do
invite all work to protect plants and
fungi for all of us
just walking around a garden you feel
better now that's not just visual it's
the fact that you're absorbing the
essential oils from a plant that we know
have an effect on your nervous system
make you feel better how do you capture
that knowledge exactly which of the
plants that do that that's a key to a
lot of our research here at Kerr the
power of plants is all around us
and this is just the first of many steps
towards fascinating discoveries to come
there's so much of the world that still
needs exploring plugs are the future
[Music]
you